vous vous demandez comment je me suis
retrouvé dans cette situation je suis un
de tueur à gaz je sais je fais le
sale boulot
mais ça ne me dérange jamais de Monsieur
lire les mains sur mes prix il fallait
que je fasse profil bas après tout ce
qui s'était passé à Londres donc j'ai
dégainé un faux passeport pour prendre
le premier vol pour n'importe où et ce
n'importe où c'était Malte il y a
énormément de gens ici qui veulent en
tuer d'autres et je peux pas tout gérer
je peux peut-être t'aider file-moi des
infos
c'était notre laboratoire ont testé de
nouvelles façons de tuer et on étudie
tous les aspects qui permettaient d'y
arriver sans laisser la moindre trace
comment tu m'as retrouvé j'ai entendu
dire que les affaires tournaient bien
dans le coin pour toi
pour réussir il faut savoir souffrir mec
[Musique]
chef d'entreprise est décidé de mettre
un contrat sur la tête de mon fils Dante
je vous demande d'assurer la protection
de mon fils quel qu'en soit les
conséquences est-ce que c'est clair
et qui vont tous vous buter je te
conseille de mettre des crampons petit
joueur
ça va être un de match de
classement mondial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
se garder en vie ta maman elle vient de
m'engagée pour te protéger
avec toi tu es vraiment un tueur et
le travail d'un tueur à gage
n'est jamais terminé
[Musique]
profession tueur 2